Julia ha recibido 40 dólares.
El número de dólares que le quedan "y" después de "x" días,
está aproximado por la fórmula
"y" igual a 40 menos "2.5x".
Grafica la ecuación y usa la gráfica para estimar cuánto dinero le queda a Julia después de 8 días.
Así que hagamos
una tabla de valores "x" y "y",
y después utilizaremos esa tabla
para realizar la gráfica
y así podemos responder la pregunta que nos hacen de ¿cuánto dinero le queda después de 8 días?
De hecho podríamos hacer eso a través de la ecuación,
lo haremos posteriormente
"x" es el número de días
y como no vamos a regresar el tiempo,
vamos a iniciar con "x" igual a 0 días
así es que cuando han pasado 0 días
pues acaba de recibir el dinero
así es que ni siquiera
tenemos que usar la ecuación
sabemos que al pasar 0 días al no haber
pasado tiempo tiene 40 dólares
pero bueno chequeémoslo con la ecuación,
verifiquémoslo con la ecuación,
"y" es igual a 40 menos "2.5x",
vamos a calcularlo para "x" igual a 0,
esto es 40 menos 2.5 por 0
este término se hace 0 así es que
esto es 40 menos 0 igual a 40.
Cuando no ha pasado el tiempo,
Julia tiene 40 dólares.
Podríamos hacer ahora para un día después
pero aquí por esta parte de la ecuación,
tendremos números decimales
así es que para que tengamos números enteros
hay que multiplicar esto por múltiplos de dos
así es que hagamos para
"x" igual a 2
para "x" igual a 2 el valor
de "y" va a ser 40 menos 2.5...
2.5
por 2
y tenemos 2.5 por 2 es 5
así que 40 menos 5 le quedan 35 dólares.
Hagamos ahora "x" igual a 4
40... déjame hacerlo con otro color,
para que cuando grafiquemos los puntos
veamos de dónde viene la información
así que cuando "x" igual a 4
tenemos 40 menos 2.5 por 4...
2.5 por 4 es igual a 10
40 menos 10
esto es igual a 30 dólares
y observamos
aquí que cada 2 días
está gastando 5 dólares
o lo que es lo mismo 2.5 dólares diarios.
Lo podemos ver aquí con este signo menos que representa que está gastando 2.5 dólares al día
cada vez que se incrementa "x" por 1,
se gastan 2.5 dólares,
continuemos...
cuando "x" es igual a 6...
cuando "x" es igual a 6 días
esto es 40 menos 2.5 por 6
2.5 por 6 es 15,
40 menos 15, esto es igual a 25 dólares.
Sigamos hagamos el último,
cuando "x" es igual a 8, 8 días
esto es 40 menos 2.5 por 8,
2.5 por 8 es 20,
40 menos 20 esto es igual a 20 dólares
de hecho ya hemos contestado a la pregunta
después de ocho días...
después de 8 días
a Julia le quedan 20 dólares
pero hagamos esta primera parte,
grafiquemos la ecuación
voy a dibujar entonces
los ejes este es mi eje vertical
va a ser una gráfica hecha a mano
este es mi eje "y"
que es los dólares que le quedan
y aquí tenemos
el eje horizontal que es el eje "x"
y nos estamos enfocando únicamente en
el primer cuadrante porque en este contexto
estamos suponiendo que sólo va a tener
una cantidad positiva de dólares,
no va a tener dólares negativos
y también para el caso de las "x"
que es el número de días
solo vamos a considerar
valores positivos de "x"
por lo cual nos vamos a enfocar
en el primer cuadrante.
Así es que empezamos con "y" igual a 40,
para este caso déjame primero poner
la escala del eje "y"
empezamos con 10,
voy a hacerlo de 10 en 10
10, 20, 30 y 40
40 dólares
marcamos ahora
35, 25, 15 y 5.
Hagamos ahora la escala para el eje "x"...
déjame usar el mismo color amarillo...
así es que aquí tenemos,
"x" igual a 2
"x" igual a 4
"x" igual a 6
"x" igual a 8
"x" igual a 10
vamos a graficar entonces los puntos.
Cuando "x" es igual a 0 días
"y" es igual a 40 dólares
este es el punto 0, 40
son las coordenadas de ese punto
cuando "x" es igual a 2...
cuando "x" es igual a 2,
"y" es igual a 35
después de 2 días tiene 35 dólares
cuando "x" es igual a 4
4 para la "x" que son los días,
déjame...
pongamos esta información en la gráfica
el eje "x" representa los días
y el eje "y" representa los dólares
entonces, cuando "x" es igual a 4
"y" es igual a 30
ese es el punto 4, 30
cuando "x" igual a 6
para "x" igual a 6
entonces "y" es igual a 25,
es este punto de aquí,
y finalmente después de 8 días,
le quedan 20 dólares...
después de 8 días,
le quedan 20 dólares.
Ya que tenemos los puntos
vamos a conectarlos
con una línea recta
si tuviéramos una regla
necesitaríamos tan solo
dos puntos para tener una recta adecuada...
déjame usar otro color para trazar la gráfica...
conectamos los puntos
y obtenemos la línea que nos muestra entonces
cuánto dinero tiene Julia cada día
hemos concluido,
hemos graficado la ecuación
y sabemos que después de 8 días,
Julia tiene 20 dólares.